gentleman called how to alpha male this
is not a bit
it's not ironic we already went through
that trust me this is real
really yeah this is real it's called how
to alpha male
uh he has 55 subs now um very alpha
yeah oh wait hey hey boys and girls it's
your friend
how to alpha male coming at you with yet
another video
this video is going to be titled women
can smell
male weakness from a mile away
so first off this new watchman tv show
looks terrible it really is terrible
secondly yesis little lips look a little
look a little slip start i mean a mile
i'm talking a nautical sea mile
women can smell male weakness like
sharks can smell blood in the water
okay so i got a weak story for you
i know it's probably hard to breathe
yeah nice mr wrestling mask
a little troll looks like mr wrestling
it's masked destroyer no it looks like
the mask toby mcguire wore
when he had to win the wrestling thing
against bone saw
you look like a tag team wrestler that
has a number in your name
you know like red face number two
on the internet and she's a young lady
and uh
she was being contacted by a young man
who she didn't feel entirely comfortable
with was the man you
were you the man were you the man this
you're the guy right
she felt that he somehow
wasn't right in some way that
that he wore a mask sometimes with
glasses
and he screamed into a camera and he had
lips like uncle larry from perfect
strangers
and you know he bought bathwater from
gamer girls
somehow strange i just got it
i wanted to give you credit those were
funny some way what she was
what she was sensing what she was
smelling is
male weakness male emotional remember
i'm sorry for those just tuning in
this is how to alpha male hey by the way
stupid you know what else women can
smell a guy
who's literally working game like who's
who has a system right you're right
it's it's literally like like if you're
a guy that's like
i i do eye contact practice videos when
i shake people's hands it's like
oh and uh this is merch and it's like oh
hello one
two three and your name sir
just like people can tell when you have
a book that you read on how to be a
human being
yeah and a bunch of girls have already
picked up on negging like you can't do
that you know
yes and she um
they got into a discord conversation and
this guy remember what do you want to
get laid boys it goes down in the
discord bro
you want to get laid ladies and
gentlemen out there you guys want to you
want to figure out how to get the chicks
you see i'll give you give you the best
tip in the world and i learned this from
patrice o'neill
you have to get to a place in your life
where you
genuinely you can't fake this where you
genuinely
don't give a [ __ ] if she goes home with
you or not yeah that's the
am i right no you're right it's the only
time that you're free
and you can just go up and talk to a
girl and after two minutes of talking
and be like yo so
like what's up you gonna buy me a drink
or what oh we just gonna [ __ ] around all
night like
you gotta be kind of a dick and really
genuinely be willing
like it's the same way in business you
gotta be willing to you gotta
peop they will hire a guy that doesn't
need this [ __ ] job
before they hire the guy that needs it
right you're right when you come in like
yeah
whatever man look here's my here's my
resume i mean it speaks for itself and
i'm not doing this
like i know you said 55 and that's cool
but i mean i'm not doing it for less
than 62.
so i mean figure it out you know what
the guy that comes in and goes
doesn't even ask about pay and they're
like okay
you're like all right they don't nobody
wants that pursuit of happiness [ __ ]
right um they can smell male weakness a
mile away
i know because they always tell me they
can smell me from a mile away
well let me tell you because he's also
an intellectual type check this out
howdy duty there neighborinos it's your
friendo how
to alpha male coming at you again with
yet another video you know what's going
to be crazy when we see this video
on cnn one day after a shooting it's
going to be this this is not what it
looks like
he went by how to alpha male a known
member of the all
theater shooting suspect identified
exactly
this guy like oh no
probably thought i was dead or something
we could only
his accomplice 27 year old ethan hansen
of clam gold's alaska you're like oh no
they're not oh
no they were in concert snipers just
going around banging each other and
shooting people i mean for all we know
this might be
this might be e-frog
concept of emotional utility
actually this dude sounds exists friends
this guy sounds
creepily like uh my my old dear friend
john mcqueen
who i used to tour with we do a lot of
comedy with he's my roommate for a while
uh he really he sounds like a
tragically uncool version of john
mcqueen
because john was cool as [ __ ] but this
guy is the exact same voice
but john sounded way more like a pothead
like he had that exact voice but he was
always like
oh yeah dude i don't [ __ ] care about
any of this
it just doesn't exist family doesn't
exist
companionship doesn't exist it does what
does exist
is the concept of emotional utility
what is emotion i read way too many
mgtow what
that's exactly what you're going to
start picking up when does he say
by the way guys everyone take a drink
the minute this guy says the phrase
sexual market value i want everybody to
take a shot
watch how many times his emotional
utility watch emotional utility
is something a person or thing place a
noun
some abstract concept that
is emotionally useful to you what does
emotionally useful mean
it means that it makes you feel better
or it keeps you
from feeling worse that
is what emotional utility is
friends family love companionship
buddies whatever it's all the same thing
emotional utility he keeps
repeating it he looks like someone that
just read a vox day blog
and it's just repeating it back you see
the sigmas
are the ones that are oh god damn it
here we go
want to see a better view of his room
and what he lives like
why is he wearing the duster inside
because
look mike why is he dressed like lorenzo
llamas and renegade
that's the thing i don't understand and
if i'm gonna wear a duster should i pop
the shirt off and just wear the duster
i'm not burning the duster okay all
right so let's just move on
he has a vast cd collection by the way
as you could tell
any weird things sex breathing
not being an agonizing pain but some
people is this donkey lips
no we would be able to hear if it was
donkey lips ask
are we as human beings people kept
saying mean comments and saying how's
your dead dad and then i kept just
saying my dead dad
in some way somehow defined by the
things that we like
does what we like somehow reflect our
deeper character you know what else
i don't like is mgtows who teach
themselves to talk like this it's like
they all [ __ ] went to the chris
hanson school of yep
talking like stop a man consume
reflect his deeper masculinity if a man
were to consume media
and genuinely enjoy that media that is
considered unmasculine
even childish can he still be considered
massive you know what else is considered
childish
you know what else is wearing a ski mask
and sunglasses indoors
like no seriously that's childish
do it can he i don't know if he's very
childish dude he's got a pretty sweet
uh 17 and a 17 to a 13-inch monitor
he has a 13-inch monitor not even that
there's a video where he's making the
video and behind him i was trying to
find it
behind him there's a ddr dance board
like you know the
dance dance revolution and he even
mentions it he goes oh yeah that's my
ddr board
i was trying to find the video it it's
but look at look at the 13-inch monitor
look at all this look at the sweet dvd
and playstation 2 game collection
they're sweet they're classic
they're classic yeah you could use an
emulator but you know it's not the same
oh they actually appreciate over time no
they don't no they don't sir use your
collector's item no they're not
uh and i present to you
bronies oh yeah i love how everything by
the way i love how every group of losers
has a lower group of losers
they can pick on it it's a loser
hierarchy it really is funny
that their subculture and fandom is
dedicated
to genuinely and unironically enjoying
the female children's media my little
pony
can we give this guy the janelle push i
want this guy to get the janelle push
guys there's this new content creator
out there he's just really quirky you
know what i mean and he's just burst out
of the scene with over 55
subscribers and he's really gonna help
you
uh put these in their place these uppity
i don't get the anger somebody says in
cell peter griffin
i don't remember ever being
angry at the idea of women
no like the like i like the i don't i
don't like
uh guys like like i would i would get
like angry when i got rejected when i
was younger at the person who rejected
me but like
these guys are just like these wendy's
[ __ ] doors man they [ __ ] owe me
sex and you're like uh
jesus yeah relax man i'll [ __ ] kill
him
jesus dude
[Laughter]
it's magic and for those who don't know
my little pony friendship is magic
is a female children's television show
targeted for little girls
that first aired october 10th 2010
depicting anthem of orphic cartoon
female pony
and from what did he say i'm sorry what
word did he say
female children's television show
targeted for little girls
that first aired october 10th 2010
depicting anthem of orphic cartoon
anthem of orphic
yeah that's uh like talking humanistic
anthropomorphic means like uh like a
talking walking thing like a furry
no no he's talking about like in
cartoons it means like uh
like like like uh like [ __ ] uh what
do you call it
octane hunger force okay those were like
anthropomorphic
uh food items got it because they were
walking talking had human characters
having having human characteristics so
like him
yes nothing like valuable friends of
friendship
in the town of ponyville now that the
concepts are fully defined
we're going to be cutting into the meat
of the matter and the meat of the matter
is this
some people believe that bronies are
unmasculine is this true however
are bronies unmasculine are they
inherently unmasculine because the media
that they like
yeah they're not chad's like you yeah
that it's not an alpha male like a fat
guy wearing a lucha mask in a duster
in front of his 13-inch monitor yeah
you're real [ __ ] taking over
the world you're real gordon gecko type
he looks like what's that dude in aw
that comes out with all the creeps that
he sits on the face
the answer is yes yes they are
unmasculine
why are bronies unmasculine bronies are
unmasculine because the media we consume
reflects us as a person we are
reflected and defined by the media we
consume
do you think is this what big kevin's
doing now this might just be a big kev
new character uh little mcdonald's and
taco bell
i'll never forget and never forget how
mad i was
i was mad and i wasn't even in the car
and i was mad
i was mad finding out second hand three
days later
i was like what this one's called
cocktails my wife had an affair and had
a child that isn't mine
virgins and cucks your friend how to
alpha male coming at you with another
video
it seems you have a lot of time to do
these videos for nobody something that
needs to be pointed out
look behind him now on the left here
full screen you guys can see it
mcdonald's bag sitting in front of the
tv his mattress is on the floor
so this guy's an alpha male with his
mattress on the floor
he's a mcdonald's and bed bug aficionado
and this one is
can everyone give me money so i can move
to hawaii
you're right i'm gonna restart my life
and
you should pay for that of the cuck
ah cocktails
me 37 male and my wife 35 female
had an affair now she has a child
it's probably hard to breathe and read
because of the mask of the sunglasses
[ __ ] me dude [ __ ] me cocktails i swear
dudes
this is something else i've picked up
about this very watchful video is this
guy
he he he comes up with a phrase or a
word like emotional utility
whatever this he will say cocktails now
50 times
in this video stories of the [ __ ]
is basically this guy [ __ ] this guy
who
at least did was married at some point
and had something
but i'm gonna call him a [ __ ] well i'm
alone in my apartment put my bed on my
floor
and by the way there's a difference
between like oh you're a cook there's a
difference if a [ __ ] woman cheats on
you like
that's not your fault like if you know
what i mean that's not your fault
you know a cuck is like knowing your
[ __ ] wife is cheating on you and
putting up with it and going whoa
it's all over you know but if your
[ __ ] chick cheats on you what are you
gonna do
we're i'm just gonna do it i'm just
gonna do the whole [ __ ] thing
we are in a minute we are in our mid 30s
now
we married in 2003 we separated in 2006.
marriage didn't last too long and did it
by the way
there's another thing that i'm kind of
honing in on with this guy right
you know say we want about mgtows
they're gross they're black pill
they're disgusting but they're they they
come from a place of
wanting to prevent the misery of other
males their their ideology is all [ __ ]
up
right they have good intentions this guy
is more
taking a lot of joy in other people's
misery
he's a lonely guy with a 13-inch monitor
to just [ __ ] easily you can tell he's
lying he's
again there are other people out there
like hey i'm going to tell you this is a
cautionary tale don't end up like this
guy
but this guy's like your wife cheated on
you took your kid
[ __ ] loser like that's not why would
you take joy in that
uh a lot of people saying he's will
sasso that would be great
she moved hundreds of miles away there
was never a divorce
but during the initial two months of the
separation she told me she loved me and
wanted to reconcile
they always say that bro what experience
do you have
a lot no no seriously like a [ __ ]
this loser with a mask on
turning and burning these broads bro
he's been through so many
he don't you know he's the [ __ ] if i
had to guess how many times he's had sex
i would say twice and he paid for it
both times
twice he paid for it once all right i
think he got
got it when he was younger probably
maybe high schoolers but it was a chick
that was like
crying because her man was cheating on
him yeah he's in a bar one day
eventually i could literally [ __ ]
whoever
and he probably was like i'll drive you
home yeah
they always say that
that's basically her just saying hey you
know you are kind of useful
a little bit sometimes and i'm not sure
if i want to you know
really look at all look how much toilet
paper he has up there too
costco brother that's a lot going on man
man you go to costco you only get a shop
for toilet paper like once a year
like a boss now from head to toe costco
we get out of this thing
100 you think he wears kirkland jeans
[ __ ] why did we separate she wasn't
happy i caught her
seeking an ex's attention via email and
things just spiraled but again
these people have x's what do you have a
mask
and sunglasses he's trying to be some
alpha male isn't it how to alpha male 1
how to
female roy i love that royce presented
this and immediately said and by the way
he's not kidding
yeah i i need to establish this this
could be a guy that would have been a
great [ __ ] this would be a [ __ ]
hilarious
gimmick yeah somebody was just doing
giving bad mgtow advice at a mask
you got to slap her in the mouth show
dominance yeah exactly women like when
you
all right hey cervich get out of here
you get out
got a divorce a divorce oh look at all
the cords
look i'm the guy who busted jeffrey
epstein okay everybody knows it
i mean yeah okay fine i had to actually
file a lawsuit against a victim in the
case to make that thing happen but who
knows you know whatever
oh it's jaylen i don't know i don't know
about this hey everybody i'm mike
darnovich
this would have been less painful than
what you have now
i made plans to go and see her of course
you did because you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just like you bro would you try to
go work on your marriage with the mother
of your kids
you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like a [ __ ]
loser
this guy's like if somebody had a i
just read 4chan all day there you go
there's even a video where he's reading
a 4chan post that you could tell he
wrote
yeah no it's like it's like not all of
4chan this is like if you had an ai only
read r9k
by the end of it yeah just like the pro
these [ __ ]
well tried making plans but she was not
responsive for a couple of months that's
because she's [ __ ] another dude
and she decided that you're not worried
you see how you see how that
you don't even finish your points but
i know you i knew you were gonna break
up on this guy no you don't even finish
any of your points he doesn't like uh
women are terrible but he's not that's
what he's doing
cocktails he doesn't respond to you when
she's sucking another dude's [ __ ] you
see how that works
she's off doing you know her own [ __ ]
thing
i made plans to go see her blah blah
blah a couple months
until i got the phone call i'm pregnant
oh man i didn't want to think
by the way i love that you know most
people right
and i picked up on it like when people
are doing like i'm going to read emails
and respond
they usually neglect one of those things
and focus more on the other so the guy
that likes to make his points
we'll we'll do the so we met out of
denny's
trying to work it out yadda yadda so
here's mike and then they give a big
articulate point
this guy yadda yadda yaddas threw both
sides of it so there's no point to the
video there's nothing
it's like yeah you know we tried to work
it out yeah yeah but that's because it's
like
what anyway so then we met up at the dam
but dude that's what i'm saying dude you
can't let these women
come at you and like yadda yadda so
would you
like you're like what are you saying you
[ __ ] a mask with a 13-inch monitor
alpha male in a mask with a 13-inch
penis
there was no agreement about seeing
other people of course it wasn't a
[ __ ] he's wearing a mr wrestling mask
i'm convinced of it
it's actually i looked it up uh it's
i because i bought one of these masks to
make fun of him uh it's
it's one of the masks that football
players put underneath when it's cold
okay you know like uh i don't know what
it's called but you know one of those
you see when it's like they're playing
in the bills or playing in december
and they have the mask uh or november
they have the mask covering their faces
that's what it is
okay that's fair but it does look like
uh like the super destroyer mask
or mr wrestling god cox oh [ __ ] get me
dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] razzle me dude they
razzle him i still consider this an
affair
i remain all right well anyway you get
it this we can move on from this guy
i just wanted i wanted to introduce you
to this people out there fighting a good
fight i mean most mgtows
and these in cells and [ __ ] they're all
[ __ ] projecting their misery onto
others but this guy has a real knack for
just
projecting his misery onto everybody
else you're the lonely one pal